يجلب الأمريكيون حيواناتهم الأليفة
معهم في إجازة الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى ،
حيث يقول موقع fido.com إن هناك 180 ألف
إيجار صديق للحيوانات الأليفة في الولايات المتحدة وفي عام
2021 شهدوا زيادة 140 في
إيجارات الإجازات وحجوزات الفنادق مقارنة
بالفترة نفسها من عام 2019. طبيب بيطري
ومؤلف لقاءات مع طبيب بيطري في جميع أنحاء العالم
في مملكة الحيوان يقول الدكتور إيفان أنتون
إنه يستطيع أن يربط أن كلبه قد قطع
عدة أميال سفر قام هنري
بزيارتها في أماكن متعددة في الولايات المتحدة.
فلوريدا فيما يتعلق بموضوع الرحلات البرية
يقول الدكتور أنتون أنك بحاجة إلى أن تكون يقظًا بشأن
ارتفاع درجة حرارة حيوانك الأليف في المقعد الخلفي ،
فإن العلامات الأولى لذلك هي
اللهاث المفرط والعلامات المبكرة ستكون
مثل الخمول إذا انهار كلبك أو
تجاوز هذه النقطة حقًا
جاد في جعلهم في الظل على الفور وفر
لهم الماء على الفور إذا كنت
تريد أن تبلل أقدامهم ، يمكنك البدء في
فعل ذلك لبدء محاولة
تبريدهم وبصدق  أفضل شيء هو
نقلهم إلى مستشفى بيطري ،
نصائح أخرى من نادي تربية الكلاب الأمريكية ،
ضع كيس ثلج ملفوفًا في منشفة في
قفص حيوانك الأليف واحتفظ بزجاجة رذاذ
مملوءة بالماء لرش
حيوانك الأليف وفحص أقدام الكلب في أيام الصيف الحارة
يعني الرصيف الساخن أو
الإسفلت قاعدة جيدة إذا كان الجو حارًا جدًا بالنسبة
لقدميك العاريتين ، يكون الجو حارًا جدًا بالنسبة
لمخالب حيوانك الأليف
إذا كانت وجهتك الصيفية هي الشاطئ
يقول الدكتور أنطون تأكد من أنهم لا
يأكلون الأعشاب البحرية أو الرمل كما تعتقد أيها
الأصدقاء
نعم
لا أعتقد
أنه يقول أن ذلك يمكن أن يسبب مشاكل خطيرة في
البطن أو حتى انسداد معوي
يمكن للحيوانات الأخرى الذهاب إلى الشاطئ حتى
الحيوانات البرية التي قد يكون لها براز على
كلاب الشاطئ تحب أن تأكل البراز في كثير من
الأحيان وهذه طريقة رائعة لنقل
الطفيليات  إذا كنت متجهاً إلى
الجبال ، فتأكد من أن
أدوية القراد والبراغيث الخاصة بك محدثة
، وإذا ذهب كلبك للسباحة في
بحيرة أو مسبح احترس من التهابات الأذن ،
فأنا أوصي دائمًا حتى
بميزة بدون وصفة طبية  شطف الأذن
لتنظيف الأذنين والتأكد من
عدم استعدادنا للعدوى